this video was made possible by
brilliant learn with brilliant for 20%
off by being one of the first two
hundred to sign up at brilliant star org
slash went over modern medicine requires
blood it is a crucial element to the
successful treatment of countless
conditions blood transfusions are by far
the most common procedure performed in
most hospitals in fact they are so
routine that even ambulance EMTs are now
performing them in the field for
traumatic injuries the only problem is
that at least right now the blood we use
for human transfusions has to come from
humans synthetic blood substitutes are
under development but for now real
donated human blood is all we can use
this blood though has a shelf life red
blood cells the most commonly transfused
blood product have a government-mandated
shelf life of 42 days in the US 35 days
in Europe and similar numbers in the
rest of the world there's even some
research suggesting that red blood cells
deteriorate in quality after as little
as 21 days so there's a big focus on
getting them from donor to recipient as
quickly as possible even 21 days
probably seems like plenty of time but
huge quantities of blood are taken from
huge numbers of individuals and there
are plenty of steps in between donation
and transfusion in developed countries
like UK this supply chain works quite
similarly to any other the NHS Blood and
transplant division manages the process
for England and Wales about 90% of their
blood comes from donations given in
their mobile blood banks that visit
schools community centers sports clubs
and other locations donors our first
screen verbally and through a hemoglobin
test than a single unit of blood 470
milliliters is taken after a day of
collection product is taken back to the
nearest of 13 processing centres over
the following days the blood is placed
on a centrifuge where it separates into
red blood cells and plasma there are
then additional tests of determined
blood type and to assure it's safe to
transfuse and then is packaged up and
sent to hospitals via truck as a whole
NHS Blood and transplant aims to have
between 40,000 and 50,000 units of blood
in their system at any given time to
deal with surges in demand while red
blood cells will last for about a month
platelets and some other blood products
will last for less than a week so this
whole process has to be sped up of
course there are other products that
require fast transportation like fresh
fish and flowers but the difference
between these two is that if fish and
hours run out people complain if blood
products ran out people died stock out
just is not possible in the blood supply
chain which means countries have to have
enough blood in their system to deal
with surges in demand associated with
situations like natural disasters and
other mass casualty events because of
this there is always a decent amount of
waste blood will quite often expire
before it's used but that's just a
luxury rich countries like the UK have
collecting and certifying blood isn't
cheap but still they're able to spend
their way into creating enough blood
product so that there are almost never
stock-outs
less developed countries though don't
have that luxury like the UK the
sub-saharan African country of Rwanda
operates a system of universal health
care but like the population the
government is not rich so it can't
afford for much waste in its blood
distribution system the average resident
of the UK makes about 40,000 US dollars
per year the average resident of Rwanda
on the other hand makes just 720 dollars
despite being a country of 12 million
rwanda x' economy is about the same size
as the small British city of Plymouth
there's an anomaly in the country's
indicators though it sits as the 17th
poorest country in sub-saharan Africa
well in the bottom half although in
terms of life expectancy it's tied for
fourth best Rwanda has been identified
as having one of the best healthcare
systems in Africa in fact it's 67 year
life expectancy is higher than that of
some far richer African countries like
Namibia and South Africa the reason
behind this no doubt has a lot to do
with the fact that Rwanda
uncharacteristically for a poor African
country has a universal health care
system where everyone has access to
hospitals at an affordable or no cost
but in addition some have attributed
Rwanda as healthcare success to its
willingness to embrace innovation one of
the most visible of these innovations
has to do with how the country's
hospitals get their blood they've
outsourced to much of the country's
blood delivery to a company called zip
line and zip line delivers blood to
hospitals across Rwanda by Jerome this
is one of the world's first commercial
applications of drone delivery while
companies like Google and Amazon are
testing drone delivery in developed
countries Rwanda a developing country
already has a full scale nearly
countrywide drone delivery system in
service
now how it works is this the drones
currently service 21 hospitals in the
western half of the country the closest
is just 2.5 miles or 4 kilometres from
ziplines facility in Moo hunga with the
furthest being about 50 miles or 80
kilometers away any of these hospitals
can place an order with zipline pretty
much in any way they can email text
phone whatsapp anything within this
building the individual sitting on the
left takes orders passes information
onto the next person in the process and
stays in contact with the hospital
throughout the process to let them know
when their delivery will arrive the
individual on the right is then in
charge of packaging up the delivery zip
lines blood products are delivered to
them by road from the rwandan health
system so they have a supply on hand the
product is packaged into one of these
boxes the whole process is designed to
be as simple as possible so these boxes
are single-use they're assembled on-site
from cardboard bubble wrap and tape with
a parachute being made from paper that
way nobody has to drive out to hospitals
to pick parachutes and boxes up from
there
the box is passed through the window and
a bell is rung to let the next person
know the delivery is ready the delivery
is brought over to a ready drone an app
is used to scan QR codes to verify the
delivery and drone then the delivery is
placed in the body of the drone the
drone is then picked up and brought over
to the catapult meanwhile another
operator comes over and fixes the wings
on the drone while another places the
battery pack in the drone is now almost
ready for flight but first the operators
perform a visual inspection for damage
and use an app to check to be sure that
all moving components are working during
this whole process someone else is
sitting in what's known as the crow's
nest performing another crucial step
this individual is essentially air
traffic control for zipline they're in
charge of the drones while they're
flying so the first step is to
coordinate with Rondon air traffic
control to make sure they have clearance
to fly now Iranian airspace is not busy
in fact zipline has about as many daily
flights as kuqali Airport the main
airport in the country so it's rare not
to gain clearance immediately but still
this individual calls in to Kigali to be
sure from there they give clearance to
the catapult operator to launch and the
catapult operator makes sure nobody is
standing in front of the launch site
there are quite often children on the
other side of the fence watching the
goings-on from there they press the
green button an electric motor spins
pulls the catapult and the drone reaches
takeoff speed in a fraction
of a second once in flight the drone
follows a preset flight path now the
drone is autonomous it flies itself but
it has no decision-making authority it
flies high enough where it doesn't
require any obstacle avoidance ability
and if it needs to hold for a minute to
wait for air traffic to clear it's told
by the controller to enter a preset
holding pattern there are few weather
conditions that these drones can't fly
through they can handle severe wind rain
and lightning but if they can't make it
to their destination they can also use
one of these preset holding patterns to
turn around while the drones have
improved greatly since a few years ago a
critical fault does happen every few
hundred or so flights in this case the
drone has a built-in parachute that it
triggers itself to safely fall back to
the ground crucially no one has ever
been injured by a zipline drone if for
any reason a drone needs to Softline
immediately such as if ziplining were to
receive an order by air traffic control
to immediately get out of certain
airspace the controller back at base
could also manually trigger the
parachute to deploy from there
operators would go out and recover the
drones by Road the drones fly at 60
miles or 100 km/h should they reach the
nearest hospitals in mere minutes while
the farthest hospitals about 50 miles or
80 kilometers away require about a 50
minute flight to reach as a drone
reaches its delivery point the
individual in charge of communication
will text the hospital to let them know
the drone will approach the delivery
point circle around to lose altitude
then fly a few hundred feet over a
predetermined landing spot open his
belly doors and drop the package the
parachute will slow its fall but impact
is also softened by the bubble wrap
inside from there the blood product has
arrived and hospital staff just walk
outside to collect it for the nearest
sites these blood deliveries arrive in
about 15 minutes ready to be transfused
into patients critically in need but the
process isn't over yet the drone gains
altitude flies back towards the zipline
site then circles again to lose altitude
now you'll notice these drones have no
wheels that would add unnecessary weight
and complexity once they've reached a
precise altitude the drone will come in
against the wind about 15 feet or five
meters above the ground then BAM as
quickly as the drone launched it's
landed a tiny hook on the back of the
drone catches a wire midair in the drone
swings to a stop the level of precision
needed to make this landing process work
is remarkable and is eight
some into how far drone technology has
come the operators take the wings and
batteries off put the drone back on its
stand and it's ready to go again just
like that now Wanda is not a large
country physically it's far smaller than
the UK so you might wonder why they
can't just rely on blood delivery by
Road like the UK for one row Ana's Road
infrastructure is lacking while the
major roads are paved and in good
quality the majority of the country's
roads are dirt when it's dry these roads
work alright
but Rwanda sees two significant rainy
seasons from February to June and
September to December when there are
heavy rains almost every day with this
these dirt roads can become impassable
four days to the floods and mud one
solution could be to stock rural
hospitals with plenty of blood products
to last through periods when trucks
can't get to them but that would lead to
heavy wastage and save processed blood
isn't cheap it would also prevent the
usage of platelets and plasma which only
have shelf lives of under a week
therefore the drones make it so that no
matter the conditions any hospital in
the network can receive red blood
products in under an hour while most
deliveries just serve to restock these
sites about a third are for emergency
situations where a hospital is out of
stock of a particular blood product that
a patient needs now the potential
applications of this type of technology
stretch far beyond its current
application while the drones currently
deliver just blood zipline is testing
delivery of about 500 other medical
products including bandages medicines
almost anything a hospital could need so
that if a hospital is missing something
they can get it in at most an hour
they're also preparing to put a drone
base online in the eastern half of the
country to have nearly nationwide
coverage one potential application of
having two bases within range of each
other is that if one base runs out of a
product that is needed on its side of
the country a drone can be loaded from
the other base fly over land have its
battery replaced and launched again to
fly to its final delivery point Rwanda
is quite a well-suited test case for
this drone technology since it is fairly
small and densely populated but this
feasibility of transferring drones
between bases could also help create a
network structure that works for less
dense countries the Canadian Parliament
recently approved an agreement with
zipline to expand into their country
Ghana is rather tall and narrow with
density as a rule more or less
decreasing as one go
well the exact service areas and details
have yet to be announced
what could work on a conceptual level
would be to have a number of bases
within range of each other the rarest
most expensive or lowest demand products
such as platelets and plasma could be
stored at the southernmost base and if
needed could be sent north to the less
busy bases serving less dense and less
busy areas by a drone stopping at each
base and having their batteries swapped
lastly one other potential application
for these drones is for disaster relief
the bare basics needed to start
operations can be packed into a single
shipping container and assembled in just
a few days the system is designed for
places like Rwanda where Road
infrastructure is lacking and after
major natural disasters road
infrastructure often is lacking it could
be quite impactful to be able to deploy
a relatively low cost high frequency
delivery system over a disaster area
using drones like these while the
zipline system is not currently set up
for fast deployment in disaster relief
situations the company has considered
working on this for the future so they
could set up a base plane flight paths
and begin operations quickly so far
zipline drones have in their initial
deployment in Rwanda serve their mission
effectively of reliably linking rural
hospitals to modern medical product
having proved themselves with this first
deployment the company is now entering
the phase of rather fast expansion both
in the scope of their service in Rwanda
and the number of countries served
overall of course the drone solution is
just a bandage on a wider problem of
poor transportation infrastructure in
Rwanda and other developing countries
but at least in the long period of time
a developing country waits to be
developed drone technology might be an
effective solution for improving medical
logistics fast there are loads of
interesting physics that go into how
drones like those flying in Rwanda work
for example with a quadcopter there was
a theoretical limit to how large a
battery a drone can have since
eventually the extra power needed to
carry the extra weight of the battery is
greater than the extra power the extra
battery provides brilliance classical
mechanics course teaches you how to
calculate what the maximum theoretical
flying time using this principle would
be for a DJI Matic pro of course in
addition to plenty of other useful
physics concepts like all brilliant
courses this one teaches you these small
intuitive concepts behind the big
subjects and then links them all
together so that you can truly
understand what you're learning you
don't just memorize procedures and facts
if you were at all interested in logic
computer memory number Theory quantum
computing or any of their dozens of
other courses you can try a few of them
for free by signing up at brilliant org
slash Wendover then the first 200 people
that go to that link will also get 20%
off their annual premium subscription